y ellos contactaron directamente a un grupo que se consideraba neofascista
así como extremista islámico,
y con Facebook Messanger pusimos mensajes en sus bandejas de entrada
diciendo: "Oye, sé a dónde vas, yo he estado ahí,
aquí estoy si quieres hablar."
En realidad esperábamos amenazas de muerte con estas interacciones.
Es un poco alarmante tener a un exneonazi diciéndote: "¿Cómo estás?"
Pero de hecho vimos que alrededor del 60 %
de las personas contactadas contestaron,
y de ellas, otro 60 % mantuvo el contacto,
es decir que estaban conversando
con los más difíciles de alcanzar sobre lo que estaban viviendo,
plantando la duda
y dándoles alternativas para hablar de estos temas,
y eso es muy importante.
Lo que estamos intentando hacer
es traer a la mesa a sectores insólitos.
Tenemos activistas increíbles en todo el mundo,
pero a menudo, sus mensajes no son estratégicos
o no alcanzan los foros que quieren alcanzar.
Así que trabajamos con redes de antiguos extremistas.
Trabajamos con redes de jóvenes en diferentes partes del mundo.
Y trabajamos para traer el sector tecnológico a la mesa
con artistas y creativos y expertos en mercadotecnia
para que podamos tener un desafío más robusto contra el extremismo
que funcione.
Así que si estás en el público
y casualmente eres un diseñador gráfico,
un poeta, un experto en mercadotecnia,
alguien que trabaja en RRPP,
un comediante
puedes creer o no que este es tu lugar,
pero en realidad, el talento que tienes ahora
puede ser exactamente lo que se necesita
para combatir efectivamente el extremismo.
Gracias
(Aplausos)